we play nuno or what yeah what are we
doing do you guys still do intros
uh i haven't uh i yeah
let's do each other's intros hey guys
it's wardminion777 here
uh perfect i tried to mouth it along
with you so it looked like i was saying
it
okay cool thank you hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome
to uno i'm gonna talk for 12 minutes
before this video starts i'm not even
really gonna play the game in this video
so
just just zoom in on my editor just
zooming out my face look at my eyes
hi i hope you're ready for another fun
video with bob wade and i
if you like these types of videos you
would love to know that there's a
podcast where we have contained the
craziness and insanity that we put into
these videos
into an auditory format just for your
listening pleasure
there's a link in the description below
don't click it now
if you do that would be very bad wait
until the
end of this video but do not forget
be sure to check out distractable on
your favorite podcasting website and or
service today after you finish watching
this video
link is in the description don't click
it yet
you're not allowed if you do
the punishment will be severe
all right i'm going to take a stab at
this one bob but it's been i don't know
my intro don't pretend oh
i got it down no you don't howdy ho
bobbleheads and other viewers i'm my
skirm and welcome to ah [ __ ]
is it working sibilance sibilance
is that good bob the sibling the
sibilance
is 100 accurate yeah yeah that really
brought it all together
oh wow this is really let why is it
running what did they do to uno that
made it run
bad uno is advanced man it's next-gen
you guys don't know what we're getting
into in this game mode no i don't know a
single thing about this just that it's a
new game mode
and everyone watching has already left
because now they are bored they can edit
it out mark
you know you know you can do that you
can edit out
i can tell very explicitly to also
keep every single detail in he keeps
coming to me with his like
portuguese accent like oh the please
don't
let do this to us and then i'm like you
gotta do it you
portuguese man portuguese is owed to
peace
don't do this oh no
oh dude broken [ __ ] for me
your
[Music]
i made sure marcus and rachel who helped
out also they also have to speak exactly
like that whenever they're talking
you know they come to be like hey mark
do you have an idea i was like why are
you talking to me like that
oh hey mark please your videos are so
bad can we please put some madness in
and i'm like
no let's just play uno it's uno right
let's play a friendly family friend
you okay maybe wade doesn't do the
intros maybe i'm remembering now
mark did the intro yeah okay yeah yeah
hey guys this is
this is uno uh let's get into the game
guys
what deck are we playing today mark
we're playing
elixion what deck are we playing and say
it in the accent
[Laughter]
three cards you've played choose to
discard all cards oh i shouldn't read
that
all of ours are different but like they
stay the same with each so anytime like
every new game will get a new god card
but it'll always have the same
description if you get that same god
again random theme to have picked
okay each time you play an action card
yeah what is this
yeah this is fascinating oh yeah go home
oh
god this is why it's lagging my computer
because of all these graphics here
you're playing yeah this one's pretty
intensive i guess yeah
so bob's got the bald guy mark's gonna
[ __ ] i've got the sex goddess
yeah okay so oh oh
what oh oh oh okay sorry yeah i don't
know what's taking me so long it's just
very difficult right now to understand
take that odysseus
yeah odysseus oh
[Music]
mark why do you have a chained up
rooster next to your face why
don't you have a chained up rooster
we've all got these great gods and marks
you can take this one it's a good hand
bob it's a good handle oh okay it's a
good cool
cool it's a good hand
don't worry wade i'll get you your hand
back i don't like the way you said that
does anyone know what the whole thing is
you're playing that color what's with
the purple on the thing
what's with the purple it's almost
oh purple when that fills up
something happens okay all right
cool cool we'll find out what it is i
guess when it does
okay thanks get a mark all right i will
not ah dude you showed me
who is is someone talking in the
background is someone just like mumbling
off in a bush somewhere
it's not very loud it's like no it's
odysseus
you guys ready for something cool i
guess i'm about to five out of five
myself
what does that mean dude it means five
this
oh good i summoned satan oh yeah we all
get a card
uh wait no that was from the that was
from the thing filling up what you
cursed my dive i'm hot now
oh you are kind of hot now i don't know
right
fully they're into my pink pupil do me
eyes
okay i drew a card right okay i draw a
card when i don't
so long as i have a curse card in my
hand i draw yeah you want to get rid of
your cursed cards that's what the
typhoon's cursed
uh what happened i'm like you're dude
now
okay well everyone's doing cool stuff
except for bob that feels
i feel kind of left out i gotta be
honest don't worry bob it's your time to
shine
oh hooray uh i don't think free your
body
and i'm gonna five out of five myself
you're no longer the man of the iron
mask
now you are me hephaestus
how old guy hey fisties i don't think
that looks like me
hathistus cafe have
[Music]
we're halfway there well actually that's
a good color
because i can stack wait a minute hey we
may
want this color that
is not how it works oh i should have
made it uh i should have gotten rid of
the
i don't i challenge i don't want that i
don't want that
i think you're going to get that in a
lot more i don't want that
well here you can i'll give this to the
pass
pass i pass how do i pass i'd like oh
why why did i
burn that i guess i'm challenging oh
ah stupid
[Music]
yeah this is the most confusing game of
uno i think i've ever all these things
are appearing
oh we don't know if that's good or bad
or oh god we gotta stop odysseus we
can't lose to the computer in our first
game
together i do hey
mark i gotta be honest i have an idea
what this does but i'm not entirely sure
sounds good man wait i do that i can't
do math
how did you do that
[Music]
that's that didn't go so as well we
gotta get rid of our foreign fine
yeah i can't it literally can't yeah i
don't think i can either
i literally hand figured it out ah take
this oh you angry um
that their character has what is this
you ain't not good you're not good you
know what this feels like it feels like
a casino
like card game with like so many
flashing lights going on to try to make
it seem like you're not losing money
it's like one of those casino card games
it's called like them up poker
yeah and it's like yeah all right now
you get two cards now that's your hand
you get one more card but you don't get
to look at that card
that's your that's your dealer's card
what is your favorite can flip that over
at any point in time it's like what did
you just
i got to discard all carts of one color
in my hand because of my special power
because i finally got to use my special
power right hey whoa i don't know what
that is what is that
oh phoenix's power choose two cards in
my hand at this card
oh that's really cool that's what that
card does that i just played
oh well i wish i had that yeah that'd be
nice that's much better than that is
that
covers an action card what's an action
card i don't know but my power activates
on action cards
okay oh my god i literally can't get rid
of the cursed cards no matter what every
time i play an action card choose a card
to give to any player and discard a
random card from your hand
i gotta play an action card why did you
get your cursor
you're really a hole you know that look
at this
i didn't you did this
i'm pissed look at you flex your blue
whoa yeah i know right those things
become a plus four
yeah well no it was already a plus four
oh okay i just made it more so
hey bye-bye curse well i would like to
play a guard but that's fine oh yeah
it's an action card
can you do something good to me i mean
if it's bad don't do it to me but if
it's good
i don't know is it good to give you a
card no
i would like to mark i feel like you're
pretty unequivocally bad
how does that even happen what's
happening
what's happening that's happening okay
oh god yeah i feel like doing a four
minus two is just unnecessary math
this is a draw three skip you get to
pick who gets what but you can't give
them both of the same person
and they don't take effect for two turns
so you gotta remember that [ __ ]
okay i should also mention everyone
looking at my perspective i'm really
sorry that i look like a tomato i'm very
badly sunburned
you could just replace it with a picture
of you from a different period of time
and no one will know the difference
yeah uh dana put on my afro get a static
picture of wade and cut his mouth open
and edit his mouth
canadian south park guy style the whole
time i'm sorry
when did my hand change i looked away
for two seconds
okay all right uh hey your hand is i'm
taking the
not cursed one thank you oh you know
what
you have a point i'm really oh wait a
minute
wait wait my special power no way no
way my special power
[Music]
i knew that would happen and i did it on
purpose
good job wow that seemed definitely
fair and everything was so clear
well now that you guys have an idea of
what your powers are we're gonna go back
in and change it
right okay cool what okay why i got to
win man i gotta turn off that
i don't decide this is randomized who we
getting
give me the bur i got the same one i get
that i got the same one i get the [ __ ]
i need to what the hell how are you the
same battling
what's happening i need to uh i need to
turn off my webcam i just need to get to
the options it's still stuck on do
webcam
i think you might have to leave the game
oh no it's okay it's it's just broken
it's not going to do anything it's just
not there whatever it's fine
who's there me that might be what's
causing your game to lag
yeah that's true yeah it would yep oh
dude
don't worry i got your back oh well
okay ah
you okay
[Music]
okay villager
damn it that's okay do what i said to do
no listen
i'm not gonna have this hand you know
i'm not no
you know how i know you're not mark yeah
because i'm just that kind of friend
oh you're gonna like it you're gonna
like that actually
all right give that back to me thank you
oh okay good
excellent odysseus i know it's a pretty
dope ass fan right
oh god what now oh no that's not a good
one
oh oh yeah is that well now they're
they're awake already
yeah that's not good oh bob
here trade with you you can have it man
[Music]
enjoy that honestly if you
had your power with that hand that would
be like yeah it's the wind
that's a that's well as soon as it gets
back into my hot little thingies
oh no wait don't do that now we're
cursed oh god no
god geez ah as heck oh come on
oh hey mark awesome man love you
what's up and i know what's in there
you're cool for now you're cool for now
you're cool for now
you're cool oh you're awake wow why am i
the only [ __ ] bag
i'm not awake well you're about to be
like right now
you don't know are you going to somehow
not have a turn yeah i think no i'm
awake now
i'm just saying you don't know i mean
i don't know why i said that like that
i'm an old guy look at me
i'm drawing look at me why do why do i
change from a robot man to an old man in
a toga when i become awake
what happens why do i become a man from
a chicken i
we don't know these things the gods work
in mysterious ways
it's just it's like the same person but
without the helmet on
oh they get armor
hatch out of a statue bob gets out of
the man the iron mask outfit and mark
quits being a [ __ ] thanks man i'm just
gonna
do one of them no problem i'm really
glad that uh of all people to have
skipped the turn they skipped me with
the full deck of cards oh
please give me two man you have eight
cards you calm down
yeah you calm down why was i skipped by
odysseus and you get skipped again not
yeah we're complaining keep running
you're gonna drop some more now
i'll complain slightly less
oh no a convoluted card i hate that one
yeah why do you get to pick too this is
yeah i thought it was just gonna come
my way i'm glad i didn't just what is
that
well i choose who it goes to but like
who is this i don't know
what i'm hot again my turn wait no
it really might wait no no no no no no
is it absolutely honored oh man
is it actually my turn right now
jesus christ is so overpowered
this is the most broken thing in this
game right now
man you guys suck can't wait to hatch
out of my statue again next time
i hope we get the exact same gods again
oh we do
do we have excellent do we do maybe
uh please give me give me happy boys
oh now the stupid ai's gonna win because
they've got happy bowie well no why am i
always so hot
the the aries card does still discard
like two of the same colors yeah
the aries ability isn't so bad but it's
not as op is
no it's not three wait
well okay i got confused because i had
the exact
same card as i was going to play oh
let's keep tossing it back and forth
catch oh this that was going to i was
hoping it would turn into a reverse i
don't know
is jumping off because i couldn't jump
in i had an identity yeah jump in
i can't actually enable it for this game
mode oh weird
but everything else happens all the
other things happening yeah i don't
know listen i challenge it
okay well at least i still get to play
my turn right
never mind that's the other thing here
we go again
no no not again i can't ah we're good
we're good oh no but i don't have red
oh wow oh no hey high five wow
shoot dang it man have a puppy face
you're never gonna survive that one
oh yeah no jumping in god damn it oh god
why
always me the ai always [ __ ] hates me
bad things only happen to her you
no no
no oh quit your [ __ ] and it's fine
no quit your [ __ ] uh oh
here mark oh no you have the guy i just
got rid of the card for you
hey this is a good hand happy birthday
this is good happy birthday
it's a good hand you say mark yeah it's
a good hand you want it take it i got
rid of my curse
okay i appreciate it i appreciate it wow
man my
morning chicken man my my god is still
locked away
isn't aphrodite the goddess of like love
and sex
yeah yeah what are your guys is the gods
and stuff
aries is the god of war athena is like
athena is like the protector of
something i'm just going off the game
hades
like she's a little shield man
no he makes like armor and stuff that's
my god of war lore
i think actually he is married to
aphrodite yes please continue to explain
on your wealth of knowledge
oh okay well [ __ ] you man [ __ ] you just
because i
i played god of war i played some hades
i know a few greek gods here and there
is that so wrong i loved hades it's a
great game molly loves hades i've
not tried it it's a fantastic game
because it was so well made
dude aries kind of slaps how'd you lose
those areas
because i didn't get a chance everyone
gave me all the big cards
uh-huh like you're going to win like
you're going to win nerd like you're
going to
win one you haven't won this one yet
look
at that out of here you know what else
you get you know what else
no i'm not gonna do anything you can't
do anything i couldn't do anything
you're right
but imagine if i did imagine if i did
imagine dude if you had i would be so
upset right yeah you would be pissed
you'd be freaking raging yeah yeah you'd
be so pissed
i think you know who you should pick
that's not what that means
what yeah what is i just discard cards
oh i think i shook
over is there any other way to win in
this game other than having a vista
funny story i had to i played this game
mode one time before and that character
never won
really i don't believe you like if you
have multiple suits
as that guy like if you have multiple
colored cards it's harder to win but
like if you're down to just one or two
or like a really small hand i guess it's
just an auto victory
oh no i got the best i'm bald aphrodite
baby
i win you know this this game mode seems
to remove the whole concept of
you know uno getting down to the one
card it seems like that's not what
you're thinking about well
i mean like i said this this dude as
long as he gets low cards he seems to be
good
yeah four yeah four you know four no
well sorry that's all right you can have
another zero in there
listen when aphrodite busts out when
aphrodite gets out of here
you all are going down oh bad choice
idiot
okay look at this nerd what a
idiot oh okay
no we will not stand for this
fire and back never all right
we're good we're going back unreal
unlocked and i've gotten to play twice
so
cool you know you're hot now i'm
hot now all right i'll just take this
hey that's a good hand don't make that
sound it's a delicious hand
it's so good i'm gonna do this to you
that's fine
it's okay i'll take two back i'll take
two back i'm sorry that was rude i
thought i got to pick those but it's no
it's random
two of my favorite ones of those four
those were my favorite
oh that's all right let's all be curious
he scares me every time i don't like him
yeah yeah is it my turn i yes
thank god oh babe i'm not taking it too
bad
you keep those what do you get no
babe oh babe
all right let's can't we all just
[Music]
i didn't play any card actually so you
know i got that after i played all my
cards
sure right excuses the thing is well you
know the thing is actually i did nothing
up until the point so you are completely
don't you want my okay well
no no no no no this is great i got a
good hand yeah don't don't don't i see
that purple guy in the back and i'm just
like you know what i don't need more
safety oh he goes away
it's fine action card isn't that an
action card
action card isn't that an action card i
guess so my favorite
[Music]
why didn't you send me your purple card
because it's a wild
card oh you got that
you schemer got that information out of
me
i should have known since i gave it to
you but i'm kind of an idiot
that's very true just you wait three
turns and i
will probably not have this hand anymore
ah
yeah i can uh yeah i this i can
um yeah you know there's some really
good numbers
you could have chosen an eight one knit
eight one knit eight wouldn't knit eight
one
eight hey what what
what honestly this is pretty satisfying
nevermind
oh wow mark you got a cool hand dude
yes man pretty dope right pretty dope
oh hey eight wouldn't it well you know
what what is
eight wasn't it oh sorry
hey why i didn't even insult you
now you're tied with them dude it's fine
yeah we're tied
oh isn't that good no it's running
it's not good buddy and you're not my
buddy here we go buddy
we're buddy ah this is worse
this is worse this is worse
now you've got oh no person coming uh
the only thing i did
was a curse and now i do this is
terrible
take this
here comes aphrodite you take my
curse you take my curse wait
wait wait there you are wow what a
banger wow
what a slanger great
i know look what thanks guys now you're
hey
oh wait no don't do that that's not good
wait
stop it hang on i know you have yellow
right
now please but i don't anymore
do not does that count
no that doesn't count it counts because
i already had another yellow
but you still get this
that doesn't really seem fair but that's
fine
all part of my master plan well i've got
my own plus four
uh
why did i give you my my skip a turn i
needed that i don't know
i just i wasn't even thinking that i
wasn't even we got rid of this curse oh
wow oh okay you don't get plus two
wrecked bye-bye
there's one color i don't have but i
have this whatever this does
i'm discarding now okay
oh nice take some of is that good this
and also one of these nice play
thanks okay hey i can finally use my
special how is that not an action card
how does aphrodite not get to do an
action thing
i don't know what qualifies his action i
have not figured that out yet
uh okay so they're skipped bob did you
just burn the card i gave you
the one i gifted you i didn't choose to
do that it happened at random because of
rules that i don't that's not what you
want to draw at all
this hand just got soiled soiled
i'm just going to keep that stupid
number i think
get out of here you slowly get catching
up over here
athena's got the magic touch now and
just you wait
apparently all right think about this
think about this wait think about it
think about it hard and harder harder
was that good that's good enough it's
good enough it's good enough wait a
minute
i was cool man really cool cool
all right we're cool we're cool like
school
yeah wait why'd you point at me wait
yeah oh
man that was a lot of bad all at once
than me right okay let's stop them
uh uh-huh uh-huh oh god uh that's not
gonna be enough
don't stop thinking it looks like it
wasn't enough
you know what i was cursed again anyone
else isn't enough
why oh wow
why have you done this to me uh give me
that
and shut up don't wait bob wait no no
don't take that one oh that's a terrible
hand for you what do you care
no no no
oh also suck it unless
i'm mad at mark i'm awesome why are you
mad at me what
i done i gotta have this back no listen
man
come on please i need this
man for odysseus never gets to go that's
damn
yeah because the computer keeps having
good good good hands and we gotta stop
them
are you okay sorry are you okay dude
you're all right yeah i just i was
chanting minor woodchuck
wait i did the okay i was gonna say i
get to do my special ability
what in the world this away from your
special ability i don't even know
what what causes your special ability
when i play an
odd numbered card oh interesting
yes all right well
i have a new target for my aggressions
oh come on
but mark stop him why why should i
help a wade for some reason yeah yeah
yeah
don't do this actually
yeah don't do this yeah get out of here
i don't care what happens you're not
doing nothing this time someone's got a
gun to your head and you're really going
to think like wait i don't
i don't do this no
oh no wait a minute um that's an issue
that's an issue would hate for someone
to not pay attention to him
what is wrong with you
throwing the whole game here you throw
this watch
this aphrodite the goddess look at this
wow you think my dick don't swing low
congratulations mark you just screwed
all three of us in one place
i am amazing at that
oh wait a minute no hang on wait stop no
don't don't except for me
that's a hundred percent what i knew was
going to happen thanks mark
okay oh
i'm sorry that i didn't make it so you
win bob i was not even close to winning
i was just trying to force stall it
until
something better could happen like you
winning that would be the only scenario
better me
watch me get odysseus and just really
make me bald or no hephaestus ah
goddammit
[ __ ] it idiots all right bob you've made
an enemy for life get ready to get
athenade
you're gonna get a theme that's all over
you oh yeah you pass it on wait
not my fault not my problem oh that's
not nice
wait we gotta be on the same team here
mark's gonna be against me
i'm gonna i wasn't trying to hurt you i
all right wait we got to be on the same
team here okay yeah you got as long as
you don't hit me with that we'll be on
the same team
okay good that's a hard decision one of
the hardest things never made in my life
teamwork i don't i don't care you know
what i don't care
[Music]
[Laughter]
that voice right he's like
all you have to do is mock everybody
yeah i don't know why that makes me
laugh i should feel worse about it but
it's really very funny what am i gonna
do
what am i gonna do goddammit
i mean if things are i'll i'll take a
stab at a big robot man i'm good
but aren't you the one that marks those
married too uh
maybe makes sense that makes sense
oh no no no wait couldn't this be
but i'm happy with the way it worked out
if i'm honest that's
quite the no man replace that with like
the star wars episode 3
vader scream
look at that
oh thank you odysseus that's the car
that you should have played there
great play great play oh he wanted 19
moves behind play
yeah yeah he had skips he had everything
i mean he is whoa why did it break him
in there but
odysseus could have played whatever he
wanted
be free be naked get rid of weights plus
four uh excuse you
oh i don't get naked for nobody acid on
i guess
here bob i'll get rid of that you have
mark's hand working together teamwork
all right what that's
don't play odds bro hey you guys want to
see some [ __ ]
sure oh friendship
nice man got him
but now this cardy man is live in the
game
on the server with no ready to win
um
i'm gonna have any troubles what
so ever oh okay well bobby you were
gonna do something was something gonna
happen
no not lying
mark play the reverse one yeah mark
bounce it back get him i think i'm just
gonna take some cards
all right i feel like you could have
really
bob get him play the reverse oh i'll get
him
oh come on man just pass it on get the
get the sing it
ah yeah you didn't click back got him
you gotta click faster
take that odysseus aha it's my chance
well like i guess i could do this anyway
functionally it would have been the same
i guess
hey you guys don't get extra curses
that's not fair and i get to get rid of
mine now yeah
okay well no no no
oh okay oh god
i'm supposed to be hot let me win um hey
man that's rude
well just you wait till i get to do
something yeah yeah
you know what right now is your time to
shine bob all right
let's get him
just got rid of my green card how are
you getting rid of like one card
okay i could have got rid of more but
now i'm not cursed
like you idiots and by you idiots you're
just talking to me because this
is me and the guy on the computer and
the computer
i'm using my powers of love
all right mark set me up mark let's do
this
no no no not like this get him no
oh wow shoot oh i think mark might win
oh no he doesn't discard he's stuns oh
oh oh yes i do oh oh
the sweep the sweep the sweep under the
rug
she is so overpowered she's the easiest
one to win with yeah that's the most
broken god in the game
[Laughter]
i guess congrats on winning thanks thank
you i i hate to cheat to win but you
know i just i i otherwise i wasn't able
to actually like
yeah we get it we get it i'm very
terrible
at games that was the that was a very
painful loss for me though not gonna lie
you uh
yes i really swept it under you oh i got
her this time you're all screwed
all right i got the cockman i'm ready to
rock man
that's what they say about you oh bob's
the bald guy
well i'll take my overpowered hand there
i guess oh what a hand look at that
yeah i was really looking forward to
having it
hey mark hey what's up man hey how you
doing
i'm good man hey so good right now good
to hear from you
yeah yeah i'm just going to do that no
no no no
no good please it's a good move yeah
oh this is flipping back my way oh mark
[Music]
hey wait a minute challenge me i will
i'm going challenge me
challenge me i did the more cards he
gets the more powerful his [ __ ] becomes
exactly that's my strategy but the same
can be true about my shiny shiny head
oh okay
[Music]
plastic you definitely had some blue
tons of it yeah there's the blue all
right we better stop odysseus we should
all gang up on odysseus now
yeah yeah get him
see look he's awake and huh my god
get him everybody
good morning i guess i'm just gonna do
that
no wait the curl it's not like he could
have stopped it man
i know but i just realized that
i can't look i can't i can't
do it man i can't i would love being a
god chicken if you're not gonna help me
every time i'm about to win something
just stopped you you weren't about to
win
i was hey i can play my curse card look
at that
hey i can play my curse card look at
that oh look at that
look at that oh
wait can you play your cursed card play
your curse card
pull your curse card that's not your
curse card done
that's an odd card right
it's not enough to win uh uh
take that mark for some reason thanks i
had the most please
don't i don't i win can i win now poorly
no i was like one of you guys was seven
i gotta figure out what you what
no i have a seven no wow
all right now everyone just let me win
yes good good yes wait just let me win
no no no no no bald man
it'll only leave him with three good
cards he gave
literally don't me a choice sorry mark
that's okay
you know i was sitting i'm thinking of
sitting this one out anyway it's nice
and relaxing to just watch it and that's
what you did to me last round
yeah yeah what i did you added well okay
actually yeah
oh i couldn't possibly win right now by
playing a red four
and then discarding all of my red cards
could i um
no i couldn't oh but i can draw that
first try
[Laughter]
huh okay green all right
get ready for some of this
oh yeah mark wow thank you
wow man oh wait i'm going to get cursed
ah bullets and you're getting this
buckets
happy birthday it's kind of a big move
kind of a dick move not going to like
i'm gonna challenge it just on principle
that's fair i see you had some non draw
fours in there you could have played
well one was the cursed card the other
one i'm really telling about your
character i just want to say
yeah i do like not losing right away
mark you want my hand no i don't know
well you didn't even listen you didn't
even hear me out that's fine well okay
talk to me you my hand has excellent
action cards
hey at least you played your curse card
that's coming yeah that is guys going to
call that freaking
back to blue all right well i'm just
going to go ahead and do that
go ahead and do one of them stop wait a
minute go ahead and do that
how many do you think i can discard all
at once
incorrect you know what else is
incorrect
odysseus card count
take this odysseus wait no i can't i
can't do that at all actually
all right odysseus
back him up bro yes stack him up bro you
stacking bro
you stacking i'm stacking so hard like
this hey
come on man that's rude oh no not
[Laughter]
so if this is the current state of
things and i do that what happens
oh that's right it gets a pick well
mark's no threats for the winner
okay you get to discard two of them oh
good i'm glad i got rid of the odd ones
which are exactly what i need for this
particular day
one of those was a skip which i'm pretty
sure is not
well it's still been more helpful than a
six that i gotta go mark
i don't have that color oh how am i
supposed to know you don't tell me
anything why do you don't
ask you didn't it oh
you get this that's not very nice at all
hey this is this is the problems that i
have oh this is the problem
this this is the problem maybe you're
the problems
you ever think about that uh wait play a
plus two
right never mind okay i don't have one
of those well i've got some and i know
who's getting them
oh god not again hey look
cursed cards oh well don't
a six a six wow you did play a six i did
i did look at this guy
even though i said sex the first time
but that's fine the sex the sex
well wade how do you like them apples
i'm just gonna get rid of those guys oh
my
ah
how's it feel bob's it feel good doesn't
feel very good does it feel good i feel
like you know it doesn't feel good
i know it doesn't feel good it doesn't
feel good to be laughed at either
okay stop you guys are getting
[Music]
you guys getting a little hostile here
oh send it around odysseus yeah no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no send it around far away
how far are we gonna send this right
around
[Laughter]
hey wait does it feel good
no did you like the way it felt wade
oh come on baby i wasn't in fact a fan
of how that felt
i'm just saying all right let's turn it
around around wade
send it in turn it around send all right
i'll just be nice
[Music]
i'll give you i'll give you look we're
being nice to each other right
that's pretty nice yeah cool uh i can do
this
hey that's terrible guys you better
watch out boys
bear watching my goodness you saying me
you don't have no reds over there great
got that green why would you do
not four he can't get rid of four
oh good the curse is back oh great okay
please give me a card i can play
immediately
thanks curse why me
you know
oh well listen i had no choice
i'm really really sorry i'm really sorry
[Music]
i'll just take it you know i'll just
take it it's okay
good man good man okay all right drawing
some okay we got a little bit of breath
hey wait a minute oh i thought i was
gonna be
waiting ha ha hey that's what you
sounded like
i got that oh i guess is that how it
feels when i mock you
yeah every time actually oh
um my card
two curses pretty cool right okay my
card dude
that's not funny when you do that yeah
it's always funny when i do it to
someone else
because you're the nice one oh obviously
nice
all right enough of this uh smurf is not
green smurf turf is not the
green smurf we changed the colors what
i'm trying to say yeah
good good good make it green okay well
that is exactly the knot color
that we needed in this endeavor i don't
want that
i don't want any of that oh
hey wait do you want my hand no it's
really good probably debate my
powers all right bob do i skip you
mark or odysseus how would you skip the
person with the people with the most
cards because you guys are the most
likely to steal mine
all right mark it is what the hell did i
do to you
you were straight ahead of me where my
mouse was one second left
what did i do wait i don't want to do
that
wait this is all on you wait how could
you just let me win how could you do how
could you do that how much could you do
that
wait i feel like [ __ ] it's not the
sunburn i can't believe you've done this
to us
did you forget this game is such garbage
well in fact i'm so mad i'm gonna leave
[Music]
you